hi welcome to digital defense my name is
Jordan Robertson I'm a cyber security
reporter with Bloomberg and we are here
in San Francisco today to talk about the
Yahoo breach so we want to give you kind
of the behind-the-scenes story of why
Yahoo disclosed the breach that it did
yesterday and actually Bloomberg and a
private cybersecurity researcher played
an instrumental part in that so first I
want to give you some backstory about
this Yahoo breach it is the biggest on
record
it's a massive breach and it's a massive
problem for Yahoo at a really sensitive
time when they're trying to sell their
business to Verizon so the back story is
this July Verizon announces its going to
spend 4.8 billion dollars to buy Yahoo's
you know core internet assets that's the
you know the Yahoo email the fantasy
sports all the stuff that we all there
were all familiar with September comes
around Yahoo announces a Yahoo announces
a major breach 500 million accounts were
compromised November comes around Yahoo
announces that it's investigating yet
another breach and then yesterday
Yahoo announces a second breach
involving potentially a billion accounts
now to put that in context that's the
company Yahoo has a billion users and a
billion users accounts were compromised
and now it's impossible to you know to
overstate how significant this is for
Yahoo at a time they're trying to sell
the Verizon and as Bloomberg News
reported this morning you know Verizon
is considering whether to ask for a
reduction or demand a reduction in the
price of the deal or walk away
altogether so this is a really
significant development you know and one
that potentially could be you know an
existential threat to Yahoo and the
really kind of cool backstory that I
wanted to share with you today is you
know the role that Bloomberg and a
private cybersecurity researcher played
in the in this disclosure a month or so
ago I got a I got contacted by a
security researcher named Andrew Komarov
he works for a company called info armor
and he's deep in this world of you know
tracking cyber criminals infiltrating
their private forums you know and
helping law enforcement and companies
track down stolen data online
identify the culprits and what Andrew
presented me worth was very compelling
what it was was apparently you know the
Yahoo database of hundreds of millions
of accounts but it wasn't the database
at yahoo had disclosed previously it
appeared to be a second database of
again hundreds of millions of stolen
yahoo accounts and they appeared to be
authentic so we checked a number of the
passwords the passwords were were very
easily discovered in this database they
were encrypted but using a very insecure
method we start digging into it and the
story we decided to look at was twofold
one was you know was Yahoo compromised a
second time potentially for even more
records and kind of most compellingly as
part of this there was a data field that
was leaked in this this database that
was users backup email addresses so in
case they ever got locked out of Yahoo
you know this would be where Yahoo would
send like a password reset well what was
interesting about that was there were
more than a hundred and fifty thousand
people who were US government employees
who put their official US government
addresses as this backup you know email
field what's significant about that is
you can drill down a level further and
see who works at the NSA who works at
the FBI who works at CIA so you get a
snapshot of yahoo users who are also US
government employees and you can do a
third form of kind of cross-checking and
figure out who these people are and you
know what we discovered is you had
ambassadors in there you had Congress
people and their age you had FBI agents
you had NSA technicians you had CIA
managers so those are the two stories we
published yesterday we went a week or so
ago to Yahoo with our findings we said
hey it looks like you have a second
breach here that's as big or bigger than
the earlier breach and on top of it you
know the information that leaked
included these identifiers x' for US
government employees and foreign
government employees in sensitive
positions and i want to show you kind of
an example of what that looked like
from our perspective so this is one of
the charts that that andrew Kamarov
began with within Farmar prepared for us
this is a you know basic chart of the
dot mil
so that's the you know the US military
you know domain and what you see here is
the biggest proportion of those
government emails that leaked were army
addresses so these were army you know
employees who submitted again their
backup email address - yahoo so you've
got army you've got Navy
you've got Air Force you got Marine
Corps so that's the dot mil there's
another category the dot goes you know
which I'll show you next and the point
of all this is you know so this is these
are over a hundred thousand accounts
just in the dot mills alone you look at
the dot Gove's and what you see here are
the big line is US government yeah you
gov for us the others are official
government accounts for other countries
so Brazil Ukraine Australia Taiwan South
Africa on on and on now again these are
not a comprehensive database of
government employees but these are
government employees who identified
themselves self-identified to Yahoo and
which now you know who now can be
targeted by you know foreign
intelligence services and as we saw with
the the the Hillary Clinton you know
WikiLeaks drama you know her campaign
manager John Podesta his Gmail was
leaked and there were like 20 or 30
rounds of email disclosures from that so
personal email for people in sensitive
positions are you know it's a really
important you know subject and it's a
very sensitive type of leak I want to
say as well that you know this is an
interactive show so I want I want you to
write in with questions we're gonna be
checking questions here and anybody with
questions please feel free to write in
because you know the backstory here of
how this breach came to be disclosed it
was pretty compelling you know so again
we went to to Yahoo about a week or so
ago and said hey we've got this
information it appears that you have a
second breach we're ready to report that
you know can you can you comment on that
and Yahoo came back again and disclosed
yesterday they kind of got ahead of the
story disclosed yesterday and said you
know we had a billion accounts breach
that's it it's a massive deal and you
know the the kind of the existential
threat again that it poses for Yahoo you
know can't be understated because
you know if this deal is in jeopardy you
know let's say Verizon walks away from
this deal that'll be the first time that
we know of where you know cyber security
incidents data breaches has led to you
know the disillusion of you know what is
you know kind of a critical deal for
Yahoo they need to sell this company
they've obviously been facing some
pretty serious business challenges in
terms of you know losing market share to
Google and search you know and and so
and so on but you know that the issue
for Yahoo is that you know they are
still one of the dominant email
providers and one of the dominant you
know online advertising brokers so you
know Verizon as we reported this morning
is facing some you know some pretty
profound questions about this this deal
it's very clear at the very least
they're going to ask for you know a
reduction in price because there's an
interesting component of what happens
when a data breach occurs what happens
where data breach occurs is as I'm sure
many of you have seen if you've been the
victim of a data breach you know is you
know when a a company gets breached what
they do is they issue identity theft
protection that services you know they
will offer everybody who was breached
you know a year or two of identity theft
you know monitoring and remediation
services the problem for Yahoo and the
reason they haven't done that is they've
had over a billion users get breached
here identity theft protection services
cost let's call it ten or so dollars a
month for an individual at a corporate
rate you're going to get a significant
discount even if even if we're at if it
were at $1 a month you know Yahoo is
talking about potentially billions of
dollars in costs associated with
providing that service to users and the
reason that significant is for users of
Yahoo to take Yahoo to court they would
have to demonstrate some harm their
account was compromised or some such
offering those identity theft protection
services you know kind of inoculates the
company from those lawsuits and Yahoo
just can't do that so that's the issue
that Verizon is studying right now is
what's our legal liability and what are
our defenses they don't have very many
good defenses so what they're asking God
to do is
you shoulder the cost the company that
remains after this deal Yahoo you
shoulder those costs otherwise we're not
going through with it first question
come in is you know what is Yahoo doing
to solve this problem
well Yahoo is you know actively you know
resetting some users passwords and it's
also asking you know users to kind of be
proactive on their own and reset reset
passwords on their own again the problem
with this is that that's kind of a very
old-school way of doing it you know what
Yahoo needs to do is reset every
affected users password you know which
it may do you know and then again offer
identity theft protection services
because the information that leaked here
is not just email address and password
it's date of birth its cell phone number
again in the government you know example
its backup email addresses you know so
that puts yahoo users at risk for a lot
of different types of identity theft not
just a count break-in next question is
what is Yahoo do differently than Google
and others well this is a very relevant
question because you know post Edward
Snowden leaks
you know a few years ago the the Edward
Snowden leaks were a very big wake-up
call for Silicon Valley and and the
large companies in Silicon Valley like
Google Yahoo and others so what Google
decided to do based on our reporting is
they really double down on securing
their network Google is spending a
fortune trying to identify holes in its
network trying to look for hackers both
the government and the criminal variety
and they're hiring a lot of really
really good top-flight security
researchers to do that work both
directly for Google as well as some you
know kind of independent research
outfits Yahoo on the other hand from
what we've learned in some of the
reporting since these breaches became
known kind of went the other direction
they didn't listen according to some of
our sources to their security people who
said we need to do this we need to do
that we need these protections in place
and to the best of our knowledge
you know what Yahoo did was they
prioritized product over security and
you can understand why they do that
the problem becomes you really roll the
dice you really are gambling when you
don't listen to your cybersecurity
people about what the risks are because
you can have not just a regular breach
you can have a catastrophic breach and
that's what Yahoo has suffered this is a
truly catastrophic breach and if it
kills the Verizon deal it's unclear if
they can sell to end
anybody else next question to come in is
do Google and other companies also have
data breaches and we just don't find out
about them here's the reason that
question is very interesting what Yahoo
disclosed is what they are legally
required to disclose when companies
announce data breaches it's generally in
most cases not out of kind of the good
will of their heart that they want to
alert users to threats that is not why
these companies make these breach
disclosure decisions the reason they
make these decisions to disclose is
they're legally bound in you know in
basically all 50 states to disclose when
personal identifiable information is
stolen from them that's why Yahoo
disclosed again we were about to report
a story the information is personally
identifiable yahoo is able to validate
it and they disclose there isn't that is
such a small subset of the type of
information that hackers go after the
the much broader type of data that
hackers go after is corporate
intellectual property and based on some
of our reporting that's what Yahoo and
Verizon are really haggling over right
now because companies don't have to
disclose that information if Yahoo's
corporate intellectual property was
stolen such as let's call it you know
the search algorithm or you know their
technology for delivering ads to
targeted users that's extraordinarily
valuable intellectual property Yahoo is
under no obligation federal or state to
disclose that information now they'd
have to disclose it to Verizon as part
of the acquisition process or they could
be sued but in terms of disclosing it to
the public they're under no obligation
to do that so in response to the
question there are breaches that happen
all the time that we never learn about
again because you know states require
companies to disclose when users
personal information is violated if it
falls into the other bucket of corporate
IP you'll never hear about it next
question is do they know who's behind
the Yahoo cyber attack I like this
question because there are two answers
this is a very contentious issue when
Yahoo first came out with their their
first disclosure in September them again
the 500 million accounts Yahoo kind of
remarkably attributed the attack to a
state actor it's very rare that you see
companies do that and when you see them
do that it's worth taking it with a
grain of salt because there may be
business motivations
that attribution as its called you know
Bloomberg has reported that you know
that within Yahoo you know the evidence
backing up that assertion wasn't
ironclad which is what we reported you
know blaming an attack on a nation-state
actor is a really serious thing and
you've got to have pretty good evidence
to make that that claim you know it
again that's that's kind of in dispute
with you know inside the company this
breach the much bigger breach the
billion accounts again working with the
researcher in Andrew Komarov you know
what we discovered was that site those
are cyber criminals those are hackers
who sell primarily to spammers you know
kind of mega spammers and the
significance of that is you know this
breach occurred in 2013
you know the spammers have had access to
a billion user accounts for over three
years which means they had been taking
over people's accounts to send out spam
because if your account is kind of fresh
and clean in the you know parlance of
hacking
you know Yahoo's not gonna block emails
you send so spammers love that and you
know that's a pretty serious issue
because people have made a lot of money
off of this data for a pretty long time
and it does throw into question you know
was a nation-state behind the other
attack or was it another criminal group
looking to spam next question we have is
you know what user information was
accessed with the recent breach
passwords accounts content etc so you've
got basically if you signed up for a
yahoo account it's basically everything
you gave them its user name its password
I should say Yahoo hashed the password
which means they encrypted it but the
problem with this big breach is they
encrypted it in an insecure way so you
can crack the password using like Amazon
servers like you just you basically a
masu per computer or a server you know
at these passwords and you can just
crack them as well as date of birth a
cell phone number
backup email addresses security
questions and answered security
questions and answers' unencrypted
that's everything I mean that
information again could be used to
compromise not just your yahoo account
but any other accounts where you use
let's call it the same security
questions so your bank accounts you know
things like that
and I'll tell you an interesting side
note
as well working with the security
researcher you know he's one of these
guys who you know in tracking cyber
criminals he kind of monitors and
infiltrates their private communication
channels so their emails their servers
things like that and he saw a
transaction happening live which we
reported and he saw this database being
sold this billion user database to three
separate individuals those individuals
are very interesting two of them he very
easily identified as these mega spammers
these are groups that you know send spam
out on the orders of millions or
billions of emails the third one though
was not a spammer the third one though
was very compelling because the third
one was a person who messaged the seller
and said I need to check if these ten
individuals are in this database and
they were Komarov wouldn't tell us
exactly who they were he's doing the
process of notifying these people but
they were top US government and business
officials mostly that's not a spammer
interested in that information that is
according to komarov's assessment likely
a foreign intelligence service you know
saying hey we'll buy this database
because we can infiltrate top US
corporate and and government officials
via this breach that's really
significant because that's powerful data
in their hands the next question is what
you know shouldn't they go back to the
drawing board and restructure their
encryption capabilities well these are
the questions that Verizon and Yahoo are
both looking at because Verizon at this
point is basically has basically had to
disclose we lost everything we lost in
terms of user information it's all gone
so can we protect it again in the future
sure they're going to change passwords
they're gonna do other things to protect
user information but from Verizon
standpoint the Yahoo user you know user
base is a key reason why they were
buying the company you know they want
all of the members of Yahoo's you know
fantasy sports leagues all the members
of Yahoo's email services you know and
if users start to leave Yahoo or abandon
their accounts because they feel like
look this company can't protect me
that's gonna be a big problem for you
know for Verizon the good news is that
if this deal goes through Verizon is
known as a very tech savvy organization
they have some very very good
cybersecurity people there so you can
take some measure of comfort in that
they would the accounts of
we be better protected under that
scenario but structuring this stuff and
restructuring you know these protections
is a very hard you know challenge
especially when you're talking about a
merger is Yahoo guaranteed next question
is is Yahoo guaranteeing that this will
not happen again
another good question because as these
these sequential data breaches showed
Yahoo doesn't have a very good sense of
you know what compromises have happened
on its network you know and the problem
with that is as we had explained to us
by a cybersecurity kind of incident
responder as they call it my question of
them was Yahoo's been working with some
top cybersecurity investigators for the
past three months
you know scouring its network for these
breaches why couldn't they have seen
this and the answer is you know even
when you hire these top firms you're
never going to get a complete picture of
what happened on your network especially
if it's several years ago and next
question is why did they wait so long to
disclose it the answer is they probably
didn't know and they probably didn't
know until this cyber security
researcher passed the information to US
law enforcement which then passed it to
Yahoo in November so you really have to
question the level of visibility that a
company has into its own security
operations when they don't know for
three years that they lost a billion
accounts and you know I wanted to wanted
to thank everybody for you know for
tuning in today we got some great
questions and I hope you learned a
little bit about the back story of how
this breach came to light this is
something that we're gonna be following
closely at Bloomberg you know as this
deal either progresses or it doesn't
these are high stakes for Yahoo and high
stakes for Verizon we really haven't
seen that before in terms of you know
data breach repercussions and as always
we'll be discussing it on the show
you know we want to take questions
offline as well so if you have any
further questions you want me to follow
up on a future show on Twitter I'm at
Jordan r1000 so please feel free to
message me there we'll try to get some
more questions next time and as always
we do this every week every Thursday at
1:00 p.m. Eastern thanks again for
everybody who wrote in
and look forward to talking to you all
next week